yeah hello and welcome to this video
yeah this video is about a project that
is now completed and released the
English opening repertoire yeah what is
this this is a product that is released
by chest 24 I have completed this
repertoire a couple of weeks ago and now
it is released in both English and
German language I now have the English
version on I mean you can switch the
language on the side and it's an
identical product besides the language
of course from both English and in
German it's a video series of in total 8
hours so we can simplify if I scroll a
little bit down here yeah this like 7
hours
54 minutes here for the English version
yeah what's it all about it's a complete
repertoire based on the move 1c form
this means um we will be in the English
opening most of the time technically in
some cases it will be the reti opening
because it is usually called the English
if black goes like e 5 or or C 5 um but
in case of e 6 and black going a d5
later it's going to be a ready opening
technically or after C 6 as well there
are very very rare cases where I will
transpose into a regular default opening
and I think in one or two lines this
happens because it is just by far the
best option
however those transpositions are never
connected to any serious theoretical
work so there's not going to be a point
in the repertoire where say okay now you
should book by a 400-page book and learn
that because this is the main line
King's Indian this is not happening so
it's a fully standalone product that can
help you to play the move 1c for with I
think reasonable confidence and it
always helps to study even more but and
they
it is enough to play it on a decent on a
decent level if you've watched my my
channel recently um you see it's only a
play see for a lot
I was trying this repertoire out in
those in those games and they had
enormous success with it
I even think ya with better conversion I
could have even scored better now what I
want to do here is to give you a quick
overview about this what is part of the
repertoire so we start with once you
form the first and arguably and biggest
part of the repertoire deals with the
move 1e5 so the reversed Sicilian um I
suggest to play the move g3 here in this
position very early g3 I think this is
the most consistent move also form move
order reasons whenever you issue c4 you
have to be aware that it's a maze of
transpositions a black for example can
start with 1 e 5 but you can also start
with Knight f6 which in fact is just by
statistics the most popular move thing
is if you play g3 now black has a 5 or
c5 or whatever available so it's very
flexible so your second move should
always take into account that black can
play basically any pawn structure still
is 66 whatever and this is really
important for example if you would go
Knight c3 em it's a perfectly fine move
but it does not really fit well with
this idea of playing a quick g3 if black
now plays is 6 for example it's
basically over with any g3 ideas as
after d5 black is trying to play d5 to
d4 and this is very annoying we don't
want to play d4 ourselves and have a
Katalin where the night is wrong on c3
so it's very very important to be
consistent with your move orders for
this repertoire to have a consistent
concept I'm always playing to G 3 on the
second on saying North only yeah only
small exception is 1 b6 where g3 doesn't
make a lot of sense other than that
always to g3 so let's start with E 5 g3
black now of course has a choice he can
play the reversed open Sicilian with
Knight f6 Bishop g2 and t5 or you can
play on the set up where he does not
open up the center or that quickly
against this my suggestion is to play
this variation up to this point here on
move eight this is the main line and now
I suggest the interesting group to be
one which is a tricky idea what wants to
play very quick before this leads to
interesting complications if black yeah
it's unaware of the best reply which is
a 5 if it does not play a 5 I think
white has reasonably good chances to get
a small advantage and then times even
more because it can get complicated and
black can easily lose the way down a 5
as I said the best move after which d3
Bishop e3 white has chances for a very
small edge it is not much but I deserve
a good position to play this is the
reversed open Sicilian and then there
are there are tons of lines where black
does not go for that one ideas c6 in
this position basically trying to play
d5 after that my ideas to go Knight f3
and play this position this has become
reasonably popular in recent years for
white and I think white has a good
chance is to fight for smaller G as well
um it leads to complicate claim and also
have here that the black players do not
know it all all too
all too well and they are more I think
knowledgeable in the main line which is
d4 which is not a bandwidth or just that
I think 93 is interesting the same thing
by the way applies for this way also to
just suggest to go Knight f3
another big complex is this and the
reversed close Sicilian against this I
suggest to play with an early route to
be one we are white placed before b5 I
cannot draw arrows here this is not an
analysis board this is just a board that
it's connected to the video this is a
nice feature on just 24 where you can
actually enter your own moves in any
given position it just doesn't have the
full commentary function okay so would
be one ready before b5 this is a common
idea in my repertoire that wide wants to
play for that long diagonal b4 b5 open
up the bishop I suggest to play in the
same fashion if black plays like d6g 6
and this kind of in this kind of
situation here now a black also has
other stuff making he can try things
like that yeah the the Karpov system
this is this kind of position where I
suggest to play with a3 e 392 and then
later d4
in all those positions I think white has
quite good control of the game even
though black is certainly not in
terrible shape he's obviously very solid
he only has played very healthy and and
and reasonable moves what I'm also I
think is this played quite often in the
C 45 complex system kind of reverse from
free not a big deal I think I have a I
think good lines with with III available
so C 45 is a very popular very popular
option I think I'm quite happy with what
I would have found there or what I
compiled there as a repertoire
suggestion I have played one C for quite
a lot over the years but I stopped doing
this
um maybe like 10-15 years ago because I
got a little bit sick of i-5 and I have
to say that when I now found and stock
of new ideas on I just said I didn't
know what at least and it's not like
they're brand new but I only learned
about them while comparing or compiling
this repertoire I'm very happy with
those ideas so I think I'm going to play
c4 more often also in in long time
control games um yeah the next big part
of the repertoire is one c5 after which
I also suggest to play g3 this fits well
because after one night f6 again there's
also g3 can be played by the way
throughout the repertoire I keep
pointing out possible alternatives so
it's not just okay here's my move and
everything else is nonsense which
definitely is not the case the English
opening is a very flexible opening where
you have many choices this is also what
makes this opening I think attractive to
many top players nowadays they of course
use it as a alternate weapon because
they don't find anything against some
main lines but they also a think
appreciate that it is a flexible opening
where many options are possible that
makes this computer-guided preparation
far less possible okay after g3 there
are a couple of options for black he can
play in a closed fashion like doing the
same thing basically after which my
recommendation is to play like this and
go for a ruby one before again play on
this Queen side and then play on the
Queen side um I think black with precise
play can equalize you know it's not that
this is a hugely aggressive option for
white but it keeps all the pieces on the
board and leads to positions where you
can definitely fight and do that in a
long game it's not that play gets
simplified there are still over a couple
of interesting ideas there that should
be mentioned for example some some lines
like if
I get punished immediately with before
wine often can sacrifice upon him
another line that I looked at for
example is a three I have to remember
this actually not that easy a three mmm
what was the line a 3m is b6 III yeah
I've had a couple of interesting ideas
there that I think can catch a black
player easily unawares
um this is the closed line black also
can opt for a quick d5 opening up the
position himself yeah this is also quite
interesting here I have actually two
suggestions the move Queen to a form
which is very tricky for black if it
doesn't know his his theory and there he
will get into trouble very very likely
why I suggest alternatively this idea
which is quite poisonous wide again
wants to play for a quick before if
black goes 45 one he has this option to
play even h4 if g6 is played leading to
very original positions here with an
early age form I think this is an
interesting line for white getting the
c4 c5 complex there is really not much
else which is of any serious importance
black sometimes play stuff like this but
white always I think his chances for an
edge here I mean there are trans
positions to the taraj now with d5 but
which is maybe the best option
objectively speaking if black plays for
some kind of hedge Hawk with a six and
Queen c7 white will get an advantage
because black is committed to those
moves very already on and that does not
equalize so no problems there for white
at all c4 c5 whatever is in general a
very very solid option so it's not
something where you can expect them a
huge advantage out of the band next part
of the repertoire is one c6 and here in
this particular position
this is a very nice example of the
flexibility of this opening here white
can play
I mean reasonably four five six
different things while against default
and say if we compare this to d4 d5 c4
c6 here white just plays a Slav okay he
can choose now I can play the exchange
she can play this whatever he has a
couple of options but compared after c4
c6 now white can do all that because
after d4 d5 we get a Slav but it can
also play E for transporting to a cow
account all of a sudden oh no it could
easily get into the pan of attack or he
can play g3 which is my recommendation
after d5 93 leading to a regi opening or
you can play Knight f3 d5 III which is
also quite poisonous this line I think
is actually quite interesting and would
have made good material for this for
this series but there are transposition
issues of course because well black can
always play Knight f6 g36 and then you
committed to g3 yeah so what I'm looking
at at the end is this line where white
offers a pawn on c4 this leads to a very
interesting plane I think the best
option for black is to actually take on
c4 which leads to really right positions
this is maybe is one of the sharpest
parts of this repertoire it's good to
know that here there are also some traps
for black
for example the normal-looking move
Bishop g4 can easily lead into huge
issues in a line like this where the
black bishop here is in danger of being
trapped with h5 here black is in some
trouble already but it happens all over
again because of such a natural move so
let here can play on solid moves Bishop
g4 Bishop a5 as I said in all those I
think a white has chances for a slight
pool it depends a little bit
how precise blackest is playing if he is
playing very precisely
he has equalizing a chance of course but
it's so quite nice for white g6 also
sometimes played after which b3 I think
is there is it good answer yeah it's
something like this it's um it's a quite
option but I think white it has some
more effective pieces yeah the bishop 1
b2 is strong and you can always yeah you
can initiate play quicker on the Queen
side years wide and sometimes you can
take at the right moment on d5 or there
are other ways to put pressure on the
Queen side with pieces the absolutely
critical variation is coming in this
position and this is the capture after
this castles white place in many
variations a real gambit this pawn is
just lost and you need to get
compensation for it there are some very
very interesting lines there for example
something like b-58 for Bishop d7 b3
leading to a very interesting play on
the Queen side um yam here after takes
takes White has excellent compensation
the more critical move is arguably
before after which 95 is a very
interesting idea yeah the Queen can pick
up some material there but it's it's
going to get trapped on a - there are
tons of interesting ideas there and they
all alternative some white for example
the move d3 is also quite interesting
this kind of idea so many complications
and I can show you more but as I said
it's an eight hour series so it's
impossible to and on and also I wanted
to show you each and every line there
this is a very very sharp a line that is
extremely interesting to look at him is
this this one night be g7 twin C to be
693 there should be 695 24 knight c6 is
also an extremely sharp line where I can
guarantee you if the black player has
not seen it and
is not a fantastic fantastic player he
will get huge problems it's it's a super
complicated line here for an example and
the black player has to find or know
that King d8 is the best move everything
else already leads into some issues and
it's a good example here that the
English opening is not just something
something boring yeah this is everything
else so in c4 c6 there are quite a
number of sharp lines that can happen
okay
we have also e6 usually the choice of
players who want to play Queens gambit
declined which could easily happen after
93 d5 f d4 and it's a Queens gambit and
this is not a bad option at all if you
know this opening my preposition however
is g3 making sense as black can always
start Knight f6 and we know the deal so
here we get this kind of situation it's
a ratty opening with black being
committed to e6 yeah here there are
mostly two options for black you can
play a quick caption we will get the
spawn back and I think white has chances
form a slide it's reaches really a
slight advantage here you get this back
black can play c6 or 9b d7
um or you can just keep the tension like
this after which again there is a good
choice for white you can play d4 for the
main line of the Catalan opening with
chances to press for a slight edge again
not covered in my series because I don't
do those trans positions because it's
just too much to deal with but if you
know the Catalan already or feel that is
an interesting option it's a good thing
to get in your repertoire yeah g3 is
much a b3 is my suggestion staying
within the red team generally I opt for
those kind of switch
of positions where white takes and don't
like it so much if they play d5 to d4
and we get a reverse Benoni this is
possible in my repertoire but usually
under relatively favorable circumstances
here this is a typical way of playing
where white has a very very slight
advantage it's a totally risk-free kind
of position by the way so if you want to
have a solid game against a strong
player this is the way to go I mean I
mean you really have to play an absolute
nonsense afterwards to get into trouble
and so so white position is that solid
one thing that's also covered is that
option of black I'm sorry going c5 and
going to the tirage defense the Tarrasch
is something that you cannot avoid
actually black can't always played e5 e6
Knight of 65 and so on and I cover this
line against the tirage with the nerdy
b3 I think it's interesting I've
selected a simple sub variation that can
be played without much theoretical
effort so I think this is a good a good
option a simple option against the
tirage which is also covered in this
series um I won't ever have forgotten
something really really substantial I
don't think so fun overview I think this
is quite ok and the next part deals with
the the rare moves
what is rare in this in this kind of
regard a couple of really exotic ones
but also some moves that are very
important the most important argument of
course Knight f6 icon g3 and now we have
a maze of trans positions in most cases
black now um commits with the pawns
he rarely has anything else and off nero
transpose like c5 would transpose or a 5
and so on the thing that is kind of
stand-alone
is black going g6 and now choosing
either to play in a GU style of the
green felt or in the style of the Kings
Indian just completing the fee and CAD
um in the group felt I think YTM in the
pseudo bloomenfeld on Neo Grunfeld I
think white has excellent chances for
advantage I don't see how black even
gets close to equalizing white has early
age for ideas and I think has a slight
advantage or more if black helps a
little bit in basically any line they
also play Bishop g7 93 castles just for
King's Indian and in this case white
again has a very good choice if you
played the fianchetto variation of the
Kings Indian default it's kind of
comparable to that captain an option or
what I'm proposing is to play do you
three and stay within the arms of the
English opening I suggest to play with
rupee one and before again but this is
very flexible so I forget again after d6
white can play basically anything in
terms of central setup you can play this
what I suggest you can also play a 4 or
a 3 or neither 3 there are many many
options um which makes us again a very
very flexible opening choice again I
propose this to play could group be one
this been in almost all cases transposed
to some line that usually starts with C
45 se 5 is an absolutely natural move in
this position other things here covered
under rare moves or other motifs b6
after b6 the move g3 isn't all that
great
because I don't want this to happen it
looks really quite ugly it's not
terrible for white but really not what
we want so in this case I propose oops
to go with E for Bishop to d7 and 93
after he's 692 I think White has quite
reasonable chances to be to be better
the tricky tricky move but I don't want
to explain it in detail here so just
going to say against b6 there is no g3
but it doesn't really vary us all that
much um there are moves that are almost
purely transposition alike
six for example but something that has
some value on its own is f5 the Dutch
approach of course I played g3 again
it's good to know that the Stonewall is
not a particularly great IDM against
this because D 3 E 4 is a very dangerous
option for example if we okay arguably
this is the worst possible version good
for black but this is a position where
black will suffer you know it looks very
very ugly what getting an e for all that
earlier and of course black does not
have to do that you can play the
classical Dutch with t6 in this case I
actually recommend to play with d4 this
is one of the rare cases where I suggest
to just transpose into a main line
opening simply because Y just has the
better chances against this opening
without any big effort so what else is
there there is the leningrad of course
with g6 and again white can now if you
desire so play a main line but what i
suggest is to just play in in english
style and just handle it like d65 will
happen and this is actually what will
happen most of the time because um
because black wants to do that anyway
and he wants to play this 65 it's part
of this f5 concept but we can just play
it in a typical English opening style
with before and so on it's not a big
deal actually the Dutch setup with most
to transpose into some C 45 part of the
repertoire yeah and then I have a final
more fun video where look at even more
more secure tries stuff like g5 which is
really really awful but it has been
played by some good players and if Y
does not play the reputation which is
taking the pawn it is actually somewhat
playable but this is a total reputation
and then yeah knight c6 I look at
briefly a6 yeah I know it's very obscure
but I think it's always fun to also
check out check out the the really
strange stuff so yeah it's a complete
repertoire if you if you really go
through all the videos it's 25 the
videos total I can scroll down a little
bit to see how it is structured yeah we
have I always have an intro for
everything explaining the rough concepts
and then there are the the single videos
yeah I don't think I've forgotten much
in my overview only minor things I think
I forgot I definitely cover almost of
one that remotely makes some sense even
c4 b5 I think I have something on yeah
so I think it's a it's a good way to
start with the English opening it's
always good to yeah make up your own
mind and and and work a little bit
yourself on those on those some openings
but the starting point I think with mer
upper twice is quite good yeah how do
you actually get this it is a product of
chests 24 and that means there are two
ways of accessing this repertoire in
both languages you can buy a premium
membership or chests 24 which is I
believe I should know that actually I
believe 10 euros a month or 10 dollars a
month so it's kind of it's a it's not
exactly exactly expensive and you could
with this one month membership you get
access to the whole stock of videos
which is really an excellent deal in my
opinion because you can probably if you
buy this one month erm of video of
membership and you your ideas to watch
like every video that they have you're
not going to manage and then one month
because it's simply too much content so
I'm investing this ten dollars or Euros
okay don't hit me if it's like twelve
dollars it's something like that um
anyway it's 10 euros but not sure about
the dollar amount and that month
membership gives you access to this
repertoire however be aware that if
there
is over and you decided not to continue
the Premium Membership you don't have
access anymore so it is a it's a
temporary thing however you can join for
the one-month watch it make notes
whatever and go from there this is
definitely possible
the other option is to just buy the
thing on its own at same for this you
don't need a membership of just 24
you can just buy it in the shop and this
is 20 euros I'm not sure about the
dollar amount I'm sorry I could actually
tribe here if I knock out here let me
check this I could I could check this so
its 19.99 euros this is German language
if I go to English justice it and I'm
sure watch is what they show it doesn't
have a price here it's kind of weird
it should be possible to buy it hmm
after after I have to check that if you
want the English to buy the English
English language version I mean my
recommendation is to to get the one
month premium or or a longer time span
know what you want I think the whole
video archive is an excellent deal ready
I saw you have to log out I'm sorry I
did this should work if I knock out come
on sorry I didn't prepare this him
beforehand so English and now look out
it goes back to German I don't know why
that is anyway so you can buy the
standard own thing or get a membership
of the site I think the best deal is get
a membership on the site check out the
video seriousness I mean it's it's great
stuff there's many many videos here by
Gustav song by Yusupov by a direct ski
even and so on and many many interesting
things so it's a good deal for the ten
bucks um okay I hope you enjoyed this
overview and yeah I'm currently working
on a new project by
the way it can announce it as well it's
not for chest 24 for a different website
this will be a black repertoire with the
Banco gambit and it will take still some
weeks to complete but there's something
new to look out for I'm not sure if the
target group of the English opening and
the Banco is kind of identical but it's
an interesting project as well okay I
hope you enjoy to the overview here
check the video series out I think is
good stuff bye bye